what was your first day on set like were
you a intimidated being nervous as [ __ ]
see I mean what were the emotions or
were you confident you're ready to go or
were you just overwhelmed I was
I was looking forward to meeting
taika and Jermaine obviously because by
that point I'd seen the movie and I was
such a fan and Flight of the Concords
and all that and yeah so I was just
excited to meet them but I was more
nervous to meet the cast because I was
gonna have to act opposite of Kavon I
never had the chemistry read so you know
in Hollywood that can make or break a
character storyline and I I was nervous
to meet him and so I was like oh please
because this grip is so good I knew the
script was good I was like if I just
make this pilot and the pie doesn't go
I'll have this footage right I'll have
this footage like I can keep this
because it's so good like I was like the
script is so good and I got to set and
the first thing came I was like hey man
and he just like gave me this huge hug
and he was so welcoming and loving I was
like thank God you know
and and it worked out we shot the pilot
and after I shot the pilot I knew that
it was really special like I was like we
have to get picked this is crazy like
this is such a good show uh but good
shows don't tend to last long you know
like sometimes they get canned really
quickly and that had been the trajectory
up to that part it's the casting in that
overall is just everyone is just great
yeah everyone has their own personality
is there one in particular one actor
that makes you laugh the most for some
reason it's probably a Kevon no most of
my scenes are with Kevon and he plays
nandor he's just a master of voices he
can mimic anyone on Set uh he can is he
always joking always joking
um also he'll he'll make a joke and then
he'll remember and laugh at the his own
joke that he's just made so he'll be
like and then he'll be like and he's
just laughing and he knows that like I
rarely Break characters
only human and he's so contained because
the vampires get to be over the top
Great Character of like you know almost
like a farce you know and that's
improvise constantly all the time like
our show has made a 50 scripted and 50
YouTube yeah yours is 50 improvised
that's why this cast I've never been
with the cast like this where everyone's
firing on all cylinders it's playing
like hot potato and the potatoes never
dropped we had us we had a season one
take that ended up being about 20
seconds in the show but we shot for
maybe 28 minutes of improv just let the
camera roll
28 minutes of us going off script it was
like who like it was a revolving door
kind of thing where we're in the living
room and Nando's like Guillermo and I'm
like I'm in the I'm in the fancy room
Guillermo I'm over here master guillerm
and he comes into another door and I
exit the other door he's like Guillermo
and then nausea comes in so what are you
yelling about I'm looking for Guillermo
I just saw him in the other room he goes
that room like it was like
just 26 minutes for 26 minutes no one
yelled cut and you'll never see that
footage because it was only 20 seconds
of it that you need it in the beginning
was it intimidating to for them to go
keep going add improvise go I don't for
me no because I tend to want to
improvise a lot and that you know that's
not usually the norm like in the
scripted series like you know you'll
have obviously you know you get on
certain shows and they're like this has
to be verbatim you know what I mean like
this is why like so you can paraphrase
you can't add words I like a little bit
of like ad-lib because it makes it feel
organic it makes you feel like these
characters are real and you're not like
just like I don't know what's going to
happen you know like it's not like you
know so to the T that it's just like ah
um I like improvising so for me it was
fun I you tell me to improvise improvise
all day long so the lines are written so
you have to read certain lines these are
the lines we want you to say yeah and
then do whatever you want yeah so the
we'll always do a take with the scripted
version and that's what Tycoon Jermaine
what's so lovely they set this rule up
for us even though like now they're you
know doing projects all over the world
and stuff and they'll come and say hi
once in a while but like it's now been
handed over to our amazing EPS um you
know Paul and Stephanie uh and Sarah
naftales who are amazing at continuing
that tradition where they go get one as
script written you know which is already
the scripture bites if we didn't
improvise on the show like they're good
they're so good that we get the the
freedom to do one scripted version and
then they go we call it funsies so then
Juliana gorskaya our director Kyle knew
it check our director goes all right
funsies or yeah
you know which means that we got what we
wanted we got the take scripted now have
fun